her Premiership literally ended in tears
the country I love but almost as soon as
Theresa May exited the political stage
the shock waves could be felt in Europe
EU leaders said that her resignation did
nothing to change that you use position
on the brexit withdrawal deal already
agreed well the withdrawal agreement is
not up for negotiation I don't think the
UK one said I so the question will be
whether we will renegotiate the
political declaration and that's what's
very miss very much an offering which is
also the basis of all the talks since
the visual agreement was closed the e
use chief negotiator Michel Barnier
quickly showed his positive regard for
the PM in a tweet expressing his full
respect for Mays determination and for
working for an orderly withdrawal from
the EU but some Tories were almost as
quick to throw their hats into the ring
to lead the party including front-runner
Boris Johnson who wasted no time in
saying a No Deal was a possibility in
October some reacted to that in
consternation that to how things could
now play out under these circumstances a
hard brexit appears to be a reality that
is nearly impossible to stop the British
government the British Parliament are
solely responsible for a No Deal exit
from the EU and its consequences but the
EU country with perhaps the most to lose
by a chaotic Exeter's Ireland Irish
Prime Minister Lee / attica had this
warning obviously as anyone can see
British politics is consumed by brexit
and will be consumed by brexit for a
very long time it means that we now
enter a new phase when it comes to
breakfast and a face that may be a very
dangerous one for Ireland while the race
for the next leader is on Europe is well
aware that he or she won't be chosen by
the British people but by the
Conservative Party members that means
nought point two percent of the country
the Tory party members who are
predominantly male with an average age
of 57 will decide who leads the UK into
this next crucial phase let's reinvent
who - man he's a pro EU activist and the
vice president of the lobbying associate
in European movement welcome to the show
nearly all commentators agree that
Theresa May is the latest casualty of
the brixon Fiasco but isn't she also the
victim of a relentless EU no it's not
all like this it's all made and by
Britain that's a UK made disaster if you
want to say that the European Union
keeps calm and carries on it looks
likely that May will be replaced by a
more pro hard Phrixus leader what is the
EU say to that some of the leaders have
already stepped out saying that the
withdrawal agreement that is on the
table right now will not be renegotiated
so where do we go from here like I said
that can keep calm and carry on they
wait and see we have to see us there
European elections now running across
the continent so they have to wait also
for a new Commission 30th of October is
the deadline for a No Deal or extension
what there's no deal scenario is
certainly one that the EU wants to avoid
but leaders coming in possibly not so
eager on avoiding this scenario how does
the EU deal with that they can't just
keep calm and carry on I assume
nobody wants a No Deal and a harsh harsh
brexit but of course that is a decision
of the UK government whatever is going
on there can be even new elections so
nobody knows really what is going on
investments are these days so what are
we gonna have is for sure a commission
of member states of the eu-27 who will
have a clear line what can have the EU
as such so that will try to avoid to
harm the EU brexit and the brexit
movement is just one example of the
anti-eu sentiment that's that's growing
and the entire block how strong is
citizen support for the EU the last yeah
the last results projections for example
in the Netherlands show that there's a
much more wider Pro
you approach so the the real threat is
there of course but in the end of the
day I guess and that especially practice
it made people thinking about what it
means when you'd get out of the EU it's
a lot of curves but there's Euroskeptic
governments and in Italy and Hungary how
does a EU plan to deal with that in the
future nobody of these mentioned
government's wants to leave the EU the
US democracy which is also scrambling on
the right policy that about climate
change policy the right immigration
policy of course these are the things
what everybody has to deal with but
nobody wants to leave the EU we need a
strong Parliament now to act to elect
the new commission president and that
comes next and that makes the EU
stronger when the people go to vote and
also vote for constructive parties well
the polls are indicating that the
breakfast party for example will be the
strongest force in the British EU
elections how strong can that Parliament
really be if a big part of it is made up
of Euroskeptics it's not a big part
which we just made it too big part of my
point of view of course but this is not
at all a blocking majority or anything
blocking minority if you want um that is
the European elections will show that in
many countries the centre will hold very
strong and already the Netherlands
showed first good indications and when
you go to Ireland you're sort of another
wave everything is a predicted
prediction this is not clear yet but
we're gonna have something what is yeah
we can deal with with democratic parties
and a real fight about the right policy
and that would make the anti European
parties much more calm Ben Tate Montreux
you activist and vice-president of the
European movement thank you very much
you